it's been nearly four years since
longmire came to its conclusion on
netflix and it's an ending that still
has fans of the modern western show
talking this is the ending of longmire
explained
after taking henry to the casino to
illustrate its importance to their tribe
jacob nighthorse is accosted by members
of the tribe for his shady antics
involving prophets from the casino
eventually he and henry are forced to
leave after gunshots are fired in the
crowd it turns out that this is all a
plot by malachi strand to kidnap the two
men using a mole in night horse's
security detail yeah we got a lot of
catching up to do
[Music]
malachi plans to force nighthorse to
relinquish control of the casino over to
him he threatens to kill henry if
nighthorse doesn't do what he asks and
nighthorse reluctantly agrees to
malachi's demands however nighthorse had
different plans before everything went
wrong to sign control of the casino over
to henry while nighthorse is in prison
nighthorse wants a good man in control
of the future of their tribe someone not
as tempted by criminal activities as he
has been this development truly
illustrates nighthorse's growth over the
course of longmire while definitely
corrupt and shady in his own regard
nighthorse has always justified his
actions as what's best for his tribe his
willingness to step aside and let
someone else take control of such a vast
business venture as the casino
especially someone like henry who has
never agreed with his methods shows
incredible depth of character
walt is informed by marilyn a member of
the crow tribe that malachi has been
hiding on their reservation she leads
walt toward malachi before being fatally
shot by one of malachi's henchmen walt
is forced to rush marilyn to the
hospital and abandon his quest to take
down malachi for the time being
eventually and his deputies find out
that malachi is located at an old
sawmill on the crow reservation which
also happens to be where nighthorse and
henry are being held captive henry
however manages to get the upper hand on
one of his captives and escape just in
time to run into the arriving walt they
all work together to systematically take
down matthias's men malachi then hangs
night horse from a chain and forces the
cowboy sheriff to choose between chasing
him and saving someone he despises after
some deliberation walt decides to save
nighthorse walt spent six seasons
accusing nighthorse of the most heinous
crimes while nighthorse is not remotely
perfect walt's saving him is a huge
moment hey
[Music]
thank you
throughout the various action-packed
events that take place in goodbye as
always implied there are also several
side plots occurring the biggest one
arguably is the blossoming romance
between vic and walt the two finally
recognize their feelings for each other
toward the end of the show while it's a
moving moment and a natural conclusion
to their intertwined stories it does not
quite end there vic confesses that the
two will never be the priority in each
other's lives because they are
ultimately devoted to someone else walt
to his deceased wife and vic to the
unborn child that she lost in season 5
of longmire vic also confesses her fear
of losing walt this is a theme that the
show has explored since the beginning
loss and grief may feel like the end but
in reality one lives on anyway it's a
poignant conclusion to what is arguably
one of the big mission statements for
the entire show
i think that's kind of the point of
everything
after the team stops malachi
nighthorse's original plan comes to
fruition and henry takes over running
the casino in hopes of steering it in a
more honorable direction that will
benefit the tribe
earlier in goodbye as always implied
walt's admission that henry should take
over the casino despite how walt may
feel about the place seems to force
henry to think long and hard about the
decision he wanted me to run the casino
you should
what
henry has struggled with his place in
the tribe since the beginning of the
show and running the casino is probably
the place where he can affect the most
change for the cheyenne people unlike
nighthorse henry won't just assume
what's best for everyone and he also has
the respect that nighthorse ultimately
did not have throughout longmire it's
been a big assumption among the
characters that walt refuses to give up
being sheriff because he loves the job
too much however this assumption is
turned on its head in goodbye is always
implied when walt decides to pay his
daughter katie one last visit before the
show comes to an end walt asks her why
she thinks he never gave up being
sheriff and like most characters she
assumes that he loves his job too much
walt refutes this however saying that
he's simply been waiting for the right
person to replace him and he's finally
found them
the only person who can replace me
is you
this isn't a mission that sort of comes
out of left field and katie does seem
confused at first walt however says she
knows more about police methods than he
did when he joined the force katie
ultimately does decide to run for
sheriff after walt retires it's not
really something that feels natural to
katie's character but it's still easy to
believe a story of a daughter following
in her father's footsteps
the series comes to its conclusion with
walt retired and happy possibly
searching for the buried treasure that
lucian claimed to have found before his
death it also shows walt's growth as a
character as he now owns a cell phone a
piece of technology that he never owned
before it's a quiet moment and the smile
on walt's face illustrates that he is
now at peace with his life and the
things he has done some may argue that
it leaves the door open for more
longmire either with walt somehow drawn
back into another case or told through
the perspective of katie as the new
sheriff in fact craig johnson author of
the longmire books has hinted that
movies taking place after the show could
potentially happen even without that
continuation goodbye as always implied
wrapped up longmire in a way that honors
both the characters and the fans of the
long running show check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite movies
and tv shows are coming soon subscribe
to our youtube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]